The giant novelty check (cheque to our readers
of the non-American persuasion) is a comedy
staple, even if you’ve never been lucky
enough to handle one in real life, you’ve
likely drawn a cartoonishsly huge moustache
on a picture of someone holding one in a newspaper.
(Just me?)
You’ve also probably found yourself thinking,
“can you actually cash that thing?” and
the answer is, you totally can… sort of.
Though, it’s rather silly since you normally
get a regular sized check too with the big
one.
Though cashing a check is a relatively simple
affair from the cashier’s perspective, the
work on the back end is remarkably sophisticated
and involves an amazing amount of automated
technology and travel for the checks.
With this in mind, it’s clear why virtually
all checks come in a fairly uniform size and
design- it’s just easier for everyone involved
that way.
Though several million checks are sorted through,
by hand, every single year (usually due to
them being rejected by a machine for some
reason or another) this costs banks money,
so is obviously something they are very keen
to cut down on.
However, legally, there’s nothing stopping
you from writing a check on, well, anything,
such as a napkin, and then sending it to someone
you hate.
In reality, however, it doesn’t always work
that way.
For example, there are many, many colloquial
sources discussing the story of a disgruntled
man who wrote all the information for a check
onto a cow, then cashed it to annoy his bank.
If that story sounds too amazing to be true,
it’s because it is.
The story can be traced back to the very fictional
escapades of one, Albert Haddock, a character
created back in 1935 by the British author,
A.P. Herbert.
As recounted by Snopes, despite being entirely
untrue, the story is often cited as an example
of unusual things people have carved checks
onto.
It does raise an interesting issue of what
exactly a check is.
According to Brian Black, onetime managing
director of operations and technology at the
Bank Administration Institute,
It [a check] has to contain certain features,
and it can be written on anything, as long
as it has the elements, the surface doesn’t
make a difference.
A check is an order to pay someone, that’s
all it is.
Basically, as long as whatever the check is
printed on, giant or otherwise, contains everything
necessary for it to be legally considered
a check (the amount to be paid; the payer
and payee names; the account number; the name
of the bank where the payer has the account
and what state the bank is in; the payer’s
signature, and the date the check was written),
it is a valid check.
As Brian states, the check is an order to
pay someone, and it doesn’t have to be printed
on the pieces of paper the bank give you or
you bought from them; it’s just a lot easier
for the bank and the person cashing it if
they are.
In regards to giant checks, when asked about
them, a spokeswoman for iWon online sweepstakes,
Samantha Better, said that their winners are
also given regular sized checks for their
own convenience that they can cash instead.
Going on to say that most opt to keep their
giant check as a souvenir rather than go through
the hassle of actually trying to cash it.
That being said, many banks have small print
in their terms stating that they can reject
any non-standard payments, so while the giant
novelty checks are technically legal and valid
to cash, those banks can, if they choose,
reject them.
However, even if you did have the balls to
take your giant check to the bank and you
find they have no such internal rules against
it, they wouldn’t send it off in a suitably
giant envelope.
Rather, they’d more likely simply take the
check, then write all the relevant information
down on some bank stationary and send it off
that way, which is far less interesting and
would result in you losing your awesome giant
talking piece.
Since you almost certainly clicked this to
read about someone cashing a stupid check,
we want to tell you about, Patrick Combs.
The man who, upon receiving a junk-mail check
for a little over $95,000, endorsed it with
a smiley face and then cashed it.
To his surprise, his bank accidentally honored
it.
Amazingly, because the bank failed to retract
their error within 24 hours of the check bouncing,
all $95,000+ was legally his.
Since the check wasn’t valid, it came out
of the bank’s pocket.
When news of Patrick’s hilarious feat of
getting one over on his bank hit the news,
some of the finest legal minds in banking
joined the argument, on Patrick’s side.
Essentially, Patrick was home free and in
full, legal possession of $95,000 of the bank’s
money.
Of course, this didn’t stop the bank from
having their head of security threaten him,
trying to get him to give the money back.
But Patrick knew the law was on his side on
this one and had fun with it, telling the
security officer,
Give me a letter on official bank stationery
stating that you are who you say you are,
that you indeed work for the bank, and also
put in that letter the reason why the bank
is requesting the money back, as I’m a little
confused on that.
When I get that letter, we’ll go from there.
The security officer refused, apparently calling
Combs several choice names in the process.
Despite the threats, which actually made him
less inclined to give the money back, and
that at the time he had about $45,000 in credit-card
debt, Patrick eventually decided to return
it.
He had meant it as a joke and didn’t actually
want to take any money from anyone, not the
bank or even the junk mailer who had sent
it to him.
He didn’t come off too badly over the thing,
though.
To this day, he’s still riding the coattails
of the story to make a living in his 75 minute
Man 1, Bank 0 stage show.
He was even once hired to perform the show
at a major banker’s conference.
Presumably this functions as something of
a campfire horror story at banking executive
retreats.